this message is brought to you by
Deadpool okay ladies listen up if you
catch your man with his hands down his
pants blame me I've been telling him to
check his walnuts for lumps and bumps so
we can give testicular cancer a kick in
the balls but my good deeds don't stop
there
did you know that one in eight women
will be diagnosed with breast cancer at
some point in their life so it looks
like you've got some fumbling to do
yourself watch this video and try not to
think of me while it's on seriously
self-examination is an important part of
detecting the early signs of breast
cancer and as well as having mammograms
and regular check-ups with your doctor
it's recommended that every woman checks
herself at least once a month
firstly stand in front of a mirror to
look and feel for noticeable changes
such as dimpling size difference or
nipple discharge hold your arms in four
different positions at your sides
overhead hands pressed on hips and
leaning forward next lie on your back
with a pillow under your right shoulder
and your right hand under your head with
your four fingers of your left hand make
small circular motions follow an
up-and-down pattern over the entire
breast area under the arms and up to the
shoulder bone pressing firmly repeat
using right hand on left breast finally
while bathing raise your right arm and
check your right breast with a soapy
left hand and fingers flat using the
method described when lying down repeat
this on the other side follow these
simple procedures and let your doctor
know if you find anything out of the
ordinary thank you for watching and good
health
there you have it a film that could save
your life
with boobs there's something for
everyone
you're welcome planet Earth
hey youtubers its charlie news price
here Deadpool likes playing with boobs
just as much as he likes playing with
himself so thought it'd be fun to do a
video about Deadpool's wonderful history
with boobs talking about some boobs
totally for science I know I spent a lot
of time talking about how awesome
Deadpool's marketing campaign has been
but the other day they released this
character one-sheet and it just was the
funniest thing watching people realized
that it was a picture of boobs with
Deadpool stuck in the cleavage I guess
we're trying to say right boobs or evil
left boobs are awesome but of course
Deadpool doesn't give an F he'll love
you all the same but as you'd expect
Deadpool classically written as a male
comic in the 90s so boobs everywhere all
over the place mostly x-men related
boobs because he's interacted with those
characters the most you have New Mutants
you have x-force you have x-men proper
just try to imagine what happened the
first time he saw a picture of Emma
Frost his head probably exploded a lot
of you have pointed out and you're
totally correct the Deadpool is
pansexual all that means is that he is
indiscriminately sexual he's a sexual
omnivore and that even goes
trans-species trans cosmic look at his
relationship with death death is a force
of nature of course Deadpool is still
gonna try and have sex with it look at
his wedding to shkolu she is the Queen
of the Damned if the right zombie
shuffled up that would probably not stop
him technically Marvel Zombies don't
move like Walking Dead zombies marvel
zombies move a lot faster and they have
cognition they can actually think and
speak in the spirit of the season let's
rank some Deadpool boobs starting with
number 10 dr. Betty she appeared during
Merc with the mouth during that run
issues that she appears in are like
magazines that you would hide under your
mattress as a child because you were
worried your mom would find them pretty
much as close as you can get to
pornography in mainstream comics number
9 Carmelita Camacho who showed up during
a Heroes for Hire Deadpool crossover
number 8 Anastasia who showed up during
a Punisher crossover she's more of a
Punisher character anyway but yay for
sideboob number 7 Mercedes Wilson
Deadpool's ex-wife that was a really
mysterious storyline where he starts to
remember her one of those things in
comics where they introduce new
mythology with the twist that the hero
had repressed memories number 6 death
boobs she might just be a skeleton
cosmic entity the yay for death boobs
number 5 siren who actually
tried to be something of a positive
influence on Deadpool didn't really work
out but they had some fun together led
to a nice segue for my number four
Typhoid Mary the character the Deadpool
ended up having sex with during that
same storyline disguised as siren yay
four shocking reveal boobs number two
copycat we got to give her a shout-out
because she's the character of the movie
long time terrible relationship for
Wayne Wilson - she was really fun
character from early Deadpool days and I
believe we're gonna be seeing Morena
Baccarin boobs in Deadpool which is one
of the reasons why it's rated R one of
the many reasons why it's rated R and
finally tied for number one best
Deadpool boobs
outlaw and Emma Frost Emma Frost of
course has some of the best boobs in the
Marvel Universe
and the crazy thing is that she knows it
and she uses that to her advantage poor
Scott Summers I could talk all day about
Scott Summers getting crapped on but
he's kind of a douchebag in the Marvel
Universe and even sophie Turner said
that in x-men apocalypse young Scott
Summers is kind of a douchebag which i
think is hilarious but outlaw is
probably the best example of gratuitous
boobs like if you want to read a
Deadpool story that is equally as much
about boobs as it is about something
else like an actual real story
anything that outlaw appears in will do
I don't know if all those are on Marvel
unlimited but suicide Kings Deadpool max
Deadpool pulp all outlaw stories so let
me know in the comments what are your
favorite Deadpool boobs and actually
what are your favorite Marvel boobs just
just in the spirit of the moment
normally I wouldn't do a video like this
but I feel like it's appropriate given
the marketing the Deadpool is doing for
the movie I really do feel like this
marketing campaign is gonna trickle down
to all the other Fox movies at a certain
point you can't do everything for all
the characters that you do for Deadpool
x-men tends to be more of a family
franchise so it's not like you can do
x-men boobs and those marketing
materials but you can still have a lot
of fun with it really what I'd like to
see because we're getting into all these
big crossovers now is just them used
Deadpool in funny marketing situations
like Deadpool being a pervert with the
Marvel characters because that wouldn't
be an official trailer but of course
Deadpool would try to climb into all the
actresses trailers and watch them
undress so if you have a funny idea for
a Deadpool marketing campaign or just a
funny situation that you'd like to see
him in for marketing purposes for like a
short clip let me know in the comments
and yes I do think there's going to be
some special Super Bowl Sunday Deadpool
stuff film e new x-men
tough new Deadpool stuff new Marvel
Captain America Civil War stuff I don't
know what's gonna be happening with DC
there might be some Batman V Superman
Suicide Squad stuff but mostly Marvel
x-men Deadpool related things so be sure
to subscribe to get all that whatever
ends up happening I will totally make
videos for it I'm sure it's gonna be
hilarious if you have no idea what the
Superbowl is don't worry or if you hate
football all this stuff will post online
it's not really Marvel related but they
just confirmed Supergirl and flash are
gonna crossover this year it's a big
deal I'm gonna make a separate video
about that after my arrow video tonight
so just look out for that if you guys
haven't seen them all I've done a whole
bunch of Deadpool funny teaser videos
you can click here for all those a big
playlist and you can click here for my
flash episode from last night really
crazy WTF so make sure to watch the
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you